he is he he probably the richest
self-made cologne in recent years
much further than lukas podolski and
others he invented the adblock plus
trend invented the adblock plus
company
with it researchers earn a lot of money with other
companies it also serial entrepreneurs and
now he takes care of the  climate is
climate killer climate saver tim schou aha
welcome to the shooter halo
thinks you are now say because i
have you because sven schmid about podcasts
so he is the superstar from cologne
you have no idea that there are successful
people in cologne
you have düsseldorf  or where we're
going from yes
the food that hamburg but that's the
envy of that we've had so many good things
happen or so it's
definitely happening a bit less than in
berlin but there's a good scene and
yes i feel good in cologne the
choice-  kölner
before from freiburg and since
the last time i have you
are always a bit eco be
movement used to be and very much like this
typical Freiburg picture, the
eco-awareness people who yes,
absolutely, I think we will
definitely come to my
new project in the forest soon, but there
it is, so to speak, in the roots, so
I had me as a child  I demonstrated against the
Fessenheim nuclear power plant
against the b 31 ost neu I
drove my parents crazy with waste separation
as things like that
actually come from my time in Freiburg
I had a bit of a suspicion but
then your path was very
different at first now  with the world
promise then it goes even if you
don't go back to these roots
but we already mentioned that in the last
know you made the first
money with
domain trading founded the largest German domain market place at the time
cdu that is once
place business probably from
today's point of view  sold much too early,
yes, I was probably ten
years so that's why i kept
mine going. iran made 100
million sales at the time when a lot of
employees so it was also a good
good phase just
to have gone through everything from three
friends to a
listed company and to have done it all
the way through
It was a great thing for me to have done it, which
then becomes independent after
the sale, yes, and I then
actually
started relatively quickly to put the money into the new
company and yes,
then also
started
to do small tag and  and to go back to my
ecological roots, so to speak,
that i really have
after i left sedo in 2012 in
2013 i invested in nicosia
as an example and also in
a small
wind turbine manufacturer and lots of things
that somehow fascinated me a
bit at the time we just for
me so you know my question
about the size  ngen such a change that
delivers then already an eight-hour
fortune then she is
probably - yes the bike
that was already the order of magnitude and
today it is somehow interesting the
buyer then or now it still
depends on us that is a
daughter of 11  exactly 130 and an
internet group and unscrupulous or
something like that planned on the stock exchange yes exactly
jonas each time separately i think it was
understood correctly but on the internet
although the stock exchange had been on the stock exchange for a long time we
were also listed separately on the stock exchange at the time so
we had we were at the top
i think  300 million market cap
we did we actually
did what you would call a spac today
,
namely with an existing
stock exchange shell back then we didn't call it
off, it was simply
an old stock exchange shell that united
internet conveniently had lying around
where another company just
came out  apple inc was sold and
then we have this squall  stock
trading and sort of managed the IPO
through the back door
but there is a connection so to remember what
are you looking to do differently now so when the
stock market actually goes no
closer now I
am still on friendly terms with people
but now I am no longer on the
supervisory board or somehow lower
actually
already hosting and domains and stuff like that
largely out of the hosting industry for over ten
years and then at some point i thought
okay
i still have to go to the
schumacher.de energy is rented to the
fashion house or fashion brand of the same name from mannheim
and i give myself up  satisfied with the hamm ii school so th
little brother, so to speak, what
can we do with the rent but i
don't think i can revea
that is actually good so it's like
2 3 room apart
ent in hamburg it might not b
the very first ski jump location  but
somewhere further out but
makes this new dom  ain
stories on him so these points th trade not at all
so with with with blogs chain
I have nothing to do
with actually I've never become with frames
and also from the domain world I'm
really far out and should
the next big
phase in professional life was the adblock phase,
or at least you perceived it from a distance
like the tax
bought one saw early on something like that
happened you can just
show applications in browsers we have bells as a
browser extension  now
we've talked about it a
lot now and i haven't heard it
yet now let's see very briefly what's that
good yes it's actually one of
my formative projects in the
phase after 2012 will end then for
many years that's the company  o the
operators of adblock plus and now
also
adblock and the model is relatively simple as a
user you don't want to see any
annoying advertising there  you just
download an extension, an app like
adblock and we then block ads
, we refused it on our knees, so to speak,
for two reasons, on the one hand, of
course, to create for our business model,
on the other hand, but also to
close websites that do good advertising
give money to be made with good advertising and
for us good advertising doesn't
mean annoying advertising has most of us
actually don't have a problem
with advertising
if there are a couple of inconspicuous
links somewhere if there's a
static banner somewhere on the side  if there's a
picture it's
ok it gets annoying when a video tops out for the 75th time if
something overlaps sound
some flashing banners all these
things are annoying and
we said let's separate it let's
just separate good from bad advertising
good advertising means acceptance for us
and this accepted steve is by
default the user ka  nn of
course change that too, but this is
standard for the first time with us
, the will continue to be delivered and
this because of this type of advertising
tüv advertising certification that is also
our core business model and adblock
plus may be installed on several hundred million
end devices worldwide and of
course also have a certain
possibility to
decide which advertising is good and of
course we do that in the interests of the
users and but the model is just that
then the company headquarters of large advertisers
or publishers in the end also
google as factually seen I
understood I understood them
because with you  so to speak, wide
lists can
then become up-to-date, so to speak, and then
the application can be played out so that
you can carry out your business
but then pay you a list
fee for it exactly how we
certify then these these
advertising formats we check that against the
against the criteria that the  decision  It
's not up to us. Years ago,
we asked an
independent non-profit
committee to say that this
standard setting body is
certified, which is acceptable, but of course we
check which type of advertising
also meets these standards and
hears that  Of course, it is also correspondingly
complex and for that we
then charge a fee and then pass on the
advertising accordingly and
you saw that early on that
this browser extension is exciting
because it is so widespread
and then you then have
entrepreneurs  bought it and then
practically invented the business model, yes,
exactly, back then, i teamed up with the
founder of adblock plus
and then we just built a company together out of
a hobby project
and
the idea came about
together with him, he had back then  just
above all said we have to see that
websites also do that  have
the opportunity to earn money because advertising is
an important source of revenue and
there is nothing more to be said against advertising
is not per se says that
we can object to
annoying advertising and that you can say that
too is often
public  that has become a
model that also gives up many complaints against
that when many still don't feel like it I've been
there for years you are with axel
springer to say in court
last tier had won the different process
again I've seen I'm in
detail but it  there are also
factions yes absolutely that was a
competitive model we fought it
up to the
federal court of justice and then even the
federal constitutional court
already won everything right now again
in january 20 22 fresh judgment
from the district court of hamburg
where sprung tried again is a bit of
a shame  because it is actually relatively
clear that the user
should decide what happens on his computer
and and actually the basic model
has now been said and that's why
you should
actually turn to other things now but
yes it is in fact not and
the model is contested and you have to say the company
is also very successful
economically  so if a
follow-up director in the best year 2018 took part in
almost 30 million results
that is also unusual to lead yes
absolutely the company is has been
profitable for many years so it
is also independent a small group of
shareholders is kept and yes that
is so very modest down-to-earth to
have  absolutely a year is a
really a down-to-earth reference
we've never been
financed, that's why we haven't appeared
big in the in the financing
in the
blogs about financing rounds
us now, but it's
actually like a medium-sized
company you hold from
now on  until and mine with
wife and more is kept primarily and
that should have been sold there will
now be bought back a bit
with our own funds, so to speak,
but now we are also considering who
could fit in with us again
and and it is also quite good for
a change  open to the outside world so are
you just looking for more takeovers people
people or both so on the one hand
we are also expanding the management team
just again jan wittig has joined
tilllich google and google
yes great greetings and
we are of course also expanding the
team as a whole we are also looking
takeovers because you just mentioned
it is definitely something but also
actually at shareholder level there is
always the thought that there are
maybe two people who
would suit us who also help us
to broaden our horizons
he doesn’t have a small red circle  only advantages
but one is so but that then
probably more private  equity
or people who are now
getting involved it's a bit deeper pockets yes
polytec video is allowed to strategize ac or simply
that there would be the
possibility there is actually
okay okay the sausage for people but
we are now a good 200 people
and that's about it  then probably
like 60 70 million something like that in
absolute terms and well estimated
you still do the
deals yourself so if he now like
facebook imagine that he already has such
a global deal that then lists too far, so to speak,
and the country is one
the biggest revenue driver for you since has been
caught is in valley and
deals with that i did that
at the very beginning so the years
2 12 213 were great and i then
always went to valley together and many of them have
laid the foundation stone now in  for the last few
years i've only been a
shareholder and the head of the supervisory
board, i.e. chairman of the board, but i'm
no longer operationally active, so definitely
f  everyone is the country model and we're
making progress right now
probably the world's largest
browser extension but absolutely that
's us definitely and you
've added several
more so adblock plus x there are more
blocking browser extensions that have
different names then  also translated
year we have
sometimes bought something over time whereby the
extensions are actually adblock and
adblock plus the two premier and
they also have the 80 liters in the water around
the corner and the next largest browser
extension segment is
blocking out ads at all  then
we speculated about it probably
somehow cashback system or mac
systems are relevant i think so peso
image capturing issues are big with
browser extensions and oh there is
there is for every is a bit like
with apps there is for every conceivable
problem there is one  browser extension
and for you it is further g  given
that you already have, although the money comes from
this controversial world,
i mean you can say yes, that's
easy now it's checked is everything
legal of course you've decided
i'm also investing in consciously
sustainable topics and i'm already going to be
one of the biggest  ecosia investors
water is a man have a
model at the end a search engine yes
exactly ecosia came back then was
actually one of my very first
investments after I left
sedo and
then i invested a small
amount
and the co-founder of christian
kreuzer and basically his
Sister once bought her out too
, she didn’t want to anymore and then I just
helped for many years to make ecosia big too,
so I’m not not the founder,
that’s Christian, but I was one
of the more active people right in the
initial phase and you have to be there  say
I would then be in 2018 so much in
a box company so to a company  converted
into responsible ownership
the model is not dissimilar to a
foundation only without the
without the minister a lot of the
administrative balla balla balla you
often see with foundations
and therefore it is no longer an
investment but really a
passion project of mine
and that's still the case i think we
need an independent european
search engine that we also need a
search engine that
not only puts forward who
pays the most but also
puts forward sustainable solutions
and, above all, doesn't
counteract unbelievable monopoly
profits, but also the idea  we
do something meaningful with this money
we do what we think
makes the most sense, namely we simply take
the money we earn from the search engine
and plant trees with it
model who which software  e runs
the search
engines it's a mashup of different
topics so we use and ladies went
but other solutions
show it then
basically ecosia works just like google or bing
had so you protect something in and
cost result out and
actually works just like them  others
only with the serious
difference that with the money
trees are planted the money from
the at clicks
and that is bigger again every
year in which christian kroll has also been
in the podcast somehow but in 2018
around christmas time I had it in
episode 169 what
do you say sizes also how much
turnover did kuchar make you can
look it up nicosia is the most transparent
company of all i know they do
a transparency report every month you
just get a very good point i think there
are two and a half or three
million at the moment  in the month the turnover
and also of it very very high in
quotes profi  stability so
what is left and what is left
goes to the trees that means the
profitability is 0
but as I said it is
now also a company that is
responsible for a turbo christian and
I have forfeited any right
to benefit financially from it in any way
the company is
not for sale, so that's a
special case, by the way, if you have
n't had it in the podcast yet, the professionals
foundation achim steuernagel, who
knows how to interview a good to good candidate, is a new new form of company that
is now even anchored in the
coalition agreement
as  possible further form of
society is also widely
supported by the greens by an fdp by
the two in particular and
yes it is an exciting exciting
alternative model too and that is
why it is important to know that
it simply has a quasi end and is a
prophet for us  nor that inspires
this e  success now found the world to
do that i now have the next
topic so if you look at sedo danet
blocking then ecosia many
others also talk about investments cva at the same time
what do you have as a business angel
and now but as a really big
message came recently okay it  there is a
world found by you with a
volume of 350 million which is already
a word for diarrhea is the knowledge from
the anesthetic experience yes absolutely so
ecosia also motivated me and also my fellow combatants there in
many mistakes way
on the one hand I have  I've worked at kusel for many years now
and I've also seen
how a
very sustainable idea can simply become a
real company. I've
also seen what great
people you work with, so if
we have applications or job advertisements
for courses,
then we have them  really often a lot more
applications than in other companies
because we notice a few so
many peopl  we just want to work for this
topic, yes, in my opinion, the climate crisis is
simply the biggest
topic humanity has
and fortunately there are just a lot of
people who say yes, I would
like to work in a meaningful way and
fortunately we live in a
wealthy one  society and
it is there are many jobs and
most of them, whether they are developers or
social media people or podcasters or
all of them, everyone can choose their jobs
and then most of them say yes,
i want to do something that i really
believe in and there is one  very
strong motivation and since
we wanted to take over
that too and and with that also say which yes how much
how much more
we can push the
natural
ones so that are interesting for you so you are now going to be having
fun soon means sustainable means
climate change  exactly to what
kind of company is that or what is in the company dbm
we only look at companies that
climate  they are positive so they have a very
strong positive
effect on the climate we measure that is also a
core number we must have 100 megatons of
potential to save on greenhouse gases
that is very good because of me that
means a technology
really has
to be able to be rolled out globally and
with that  just to save greenhouse gases and that
is our core focus otherwise
we of course also pay attention to it
is one thing is that a great team does
the business model make sense
have the good traction so we also pay attention of
course has the same things as
much what we did there she did with  we
made five investments
that are
exciting there are food topics
here we made a plant base steak like
this a slovene team
can do it kaká substitute from the
munich team cacau you have to know that cacau is
also one of the big
problems for
rainforest deforestation  little bit like
palm oil and that's why
tatsächl  I cacau also have a very
negative climate
effect, at least conventional cacau that
accounts for the most then we did
the trick art like deco it has
that’s this wooden
credit card that also plants trees at the same time
so to speak ecosia for your
pocket
then we made recap from munich
the cups  solution the deposit system
and the last investment is a very
important one that i asked first
both here the climate effect this is
space ford from the uk they have
a kind of factory in space a factory
system for production in space and the
basic idea is chip production  into
space and i then learned
when asked what is actually there the
climate effect that you can simply produce chips in
this way so much the semiconductor so
much energy more
efficiently that the climate effect of it is
enormous and that is our
previous investment prices  but it
means yes that must somehow say to
help combat climate change  But in
the end it must also be a
company that
somehow brings you some kind of economic return, just like it
must definitely also bring a return,
we also set out to increase
the money that
investors have entrusted
to us, we believe  that
this is successful because in my opinion the next
decade 20s
will also be a decade of
decarbonization
everyone wants cables that the companies are
demanding then the
consumers are demanding then the
regulations when i have the co2 price
has reached new heights in the certificate trade
co2 taxes are now
automatically increasing every year these are all
things that co2 tor have to do
if we don’t want to collapse as a
world and
the technologies for it are still missing
and that means there will be a
push over the next ten twenty
years
be just as exhausting as digitization and there  for
does it take companies how
much money do you have to bring with you
should you be able to set up form with 53
million than i think
you have this idea hopefully many have that you
're also lucky somehow have
the situation created for you
then it wasn't created for you yourself either  just the know-how
to make stanford the capital is
at least there to put in the money
too so 53 million this is
n't your money but there can be
a bit bigger and how much
has always flowed in from others
obviously so we're one then
dad team of four partners daria
craig and daniel next to me who
also have a good deal of
experience i'm more of an
entrepreneur and also an investor but also
for the entrepreneurial side and we
have together that's what we call
commitment in gp im  fund raised
ten million altogether, which is
quite a lot for a quickie
commitment, which also shows that we
believe in it  n
then ten million are committed by
ecosia as an anchor epi but positively
the foundation has trained the life of the hood
plants as a purpose also
the purpose
or the money is basically just parked
that will someday hopefully we will be
as much as the others
pay back three or four times the money
and then it can
plant more trees adecco of course she also has
long-term commitments like many
others too many projects
don’t always run in the long term money can’t always be
used immediately and from there it
actually means something for ecosia  in the
end planting the trees is
good again but where is of course
great for us too was the eco very much that
helped to push
otherwise these courses but a normal
ltv like others also horst from your
now private assets that I
appreciate now is then even  not so big
part sits part of offices from from a
liquid part is already
relevant  in any case, because like
most entrepreneurs out there,
most of the money is simply
tied to my company and i
don't intend to sell tomorrow
and then he's
not a leader that's wonderful like the
money and where does the remaining 43 million come from?
they come from other entrepreneurs
many female entrepreneurs investors who believe in
us so we
actually already have
a good part together so we
have almost half of them committed
meanwhile
under the first swing we are of
course still more open but at the
first swing we really have
some of them  the greatest were also the
the of the german start-up scene
founder of trivago rolf the
cronos of alex am was
then the founder of next kraftwerke
quite so many many really
many companies in his more than 100 100
investors now 100 ps
already small that actually differentiates us
from  others who are
concerned but have the very aware gem  eight
because we wanted we
just wanted a lot of smart money in this first phase
and we also have a
lot with it more than 100 apps but
really only smart people who also
see a lot the great thing is yes you
have a little more people then  more
administrative effort but we
have a lot of people who
are out there walking around and who
see other great teams climatic the
ltte who have their respective expertise
in their areas and the topic of climate
touches every area of our lives
here and then people acces
it  and just say what
do you think about it you can do introns here
who does it because the expert for that
is of course incredibly valuable for us
and that's why we made a
conscious decision to
build it up a bit bigger and
normally men and women do it
now  then investors
typically expect 4x a multiplication
of the money that's a for you  also so that
you have at least what you have here you absolutely
so that is absolutely our goal and
our claim and I
think so then you should maybe
even five six or even more that is of
course even better so I’ll say
everything at the end  what goes over 3x is
good in the end yes that's not a
little money so not a little money
making a million three is
comparatively easier I hear
than making 350 over a
year exactly that's it's
actually more difficult
but  on the other hand it's like that,
too, statistics say that first-
time fans, i.e. funds that have just been founded,
perform better than later funds are in better
shape for them, so i think there are
two reasons, on the one hand, the
teams are simply the most strenuous we
have  At the beginning you really want to
prove that you can do it, because
only then will you get follow-up
financing and
everyone can confirm if it is at the beginning
manages to demand the first one is shot
at the second with money, so to speak,
and
that's why you stretch yourself insanely
and the second is that the second and
third generations usually
automatically grow if you're
successful he the others just listen
and then you come  again to bear what
you just said, namely a
smaller form
better and it is always smaller is
relative to the next generation
and compared to the Americans
and 350 don’t have much that’s one of the
group that we have more with
Europe  we have
people piling up patents for start-ups
on the same level as europe and asia
and the usa, but we only have a
third to a quarter of the venture
capital available and that's
why 350 is
actually not that much money in a global comparison  we
need a lot more of the same
kind of people we also believe in you as an
entrepreneur and then you have  also
proven now I just heard
ecosia adblock that you have a very good hand
so you buy a mixture of
entrepreneur and investor in a
personal union or something like that
go in yourself and get fit what else is there to
do with angel investments that you made,
so to speak, before it is a
deposit started a few things so
now next to ecosia
soler for example i was there relatively early
the solar roof company meanwhile
one of the biggest solar roof builders in
germany
then patsch ama come there i am
a bit proud of it because that is
no contact is a separate company from
silicon valley where i used to
invest one and then in
the very last round we sat
and got in worse today and
gates is a carbon offset in
platforms always
consciously investing in that area he yes i've
actually been doing it for ten years before that
i have my very first company in the
field was a small wind turbine  e
company with the idea, so to speak,
that you could just put the
system on the roof just like that, you could
also put a small wind turbine on the
roof the wind is a bit
more stable than than the sun and also a
bit counter-cyclical, so to speak, to the
sun and  they then sold at some
point realized they need to
go to a medium-sized company that has the
production capacity and the goods are
now also produced, so I
've already done many, many things and
it's like saying then years after
you come and see it and bill
gates the company is
billions again not yet a few
billion but they are on
the way so i think they will become one of
the climate unicorns of which
hopefully there will be very many who will
really be
both unicorn in the rating
and on  unicorn in the amount
of co2 what you save mankind ok and
that is american founding team in
the f  all of them are an argentinian
founding team but they live in silicon
valley okay and normal classic digital
companies so you don't
say he makes videos internet or
so i also made a lot of angel
investments in this
area
there are also in  especially
in the existing vehicles that
I'm right I'll continue to do
them in most cases but also
with other existing teams so
I'm not the main driver of these
topics I'll continue
to do that but I'll actually
try to connect these things more  so even now in
the world found i try to do a lot of
topics that also include software
or marketplace or internet topics
so this hand i can connect
with
with with with climate and not just
to make hardware the others, for
example, that we have in the team
they also make a lot of hardware and the
fund sits but we also say in
berlin and cologne yes that one  fund we are
we are also a child of the pandemic, so to speak,
started right during corinna and are therefore also set up
remotely i live in cologne and will
stay in
cologne the headquarters are in berlin we
have a large team in
munich two people in amsterdam one  barcelona
is now very spread out and
but it is managed quite well and
you also have to know that if you have such power of
attorney and do
it sensibly then it is so that the european
investors
also match such investments in
the i.e. europe generally wants the
funds to exist and  the economy is
promoted, that means 10 20 come
to such a fund then from
this case so they give then stop there
then the eu sort of determine it
yes you have to apply
a rigorous selection process is a
very well-known construct because there
is also a difference  to many
other government programs really
very close to the economy and I think very much
the aif of the investment funds is
very intelligently constructed and
they actually come in as a normal lp
as an investor that’s not funding
but it’s really like that if
he goes into a woman somewhere then he takes a
very close look at her, of course she has very
good data too  smarter
analysis methods
and then he goes in like everyone else
, but of course with a
large sum and I also had a
nice signal, but then
that's about 10 to 20 percent of you of the order of
magnitude, I think the order of magnitude that
funds of this size usually
have  are probably ten to 20
percent, we can also be more or
less, but that the order of magnitude
and what we also have to discuss
is we can be a little bit present at another diner,
hopefully also a larger
one,
so in that case I even mean it  thanks to the
japanese tobias schlottke is now
also your partner in a company
i ha  be
yourself we can also invest in an honest way, the biggest
thing i've ever done
is invest in the now invests in a new project
that means a few words about the club
yes that's a project i
started a few years ago
and that's what it's all about
that companies were
buying small companies because one thing the
three of them noticed is that there
is a great deal of attention to
venture-oriented is thus in
financing for the next 5
million next fifty so then
at some point pio there are all eyes on it
but it  there is a world out there of
tens of thousands of small tools that are built by
super motivated
developers over years of work
that really often serve a clear plan
so they solve some
small fine problem i will now give
an example
from our portfolio
we have  a tool that is called brender
privéeo they do nothing else than
large javascript pages to v  change
it so the google body finds it better
so this is a tool that's actually just
text eos by big javascript times they
use it as quite a
manageable market but it's big
enough for
a few million in sales and
there
really are
tens of thousands of these types of tools out there  and these are
just not guessing i had now felt
a bit like you would over
the last decades in the
industry is also with tobi i had always
seen what there is but
that there is so much and that there
there's no real community,
we don't think so for a long time, but then it
happened, and that's
and that's what it's
like, after a few years the
founders say it's like I can do something new
, or they notice  where i would have to
hire people i don't feel like it at all
and we have found a good way to
offer those
who these companies a new home a
little bit too  professionalize and
thus expand a group of
just independent sat tools and yes
we have been doing this for a few years now
and as you say
you are a great partner now
my old sedo
co-founder and good friend ulrich
essmann has been with us for many years  also
there and because a team was also built around it
, of course they
all do it full-time, the team now
consists of about 50 people and yes, that’s
actually another
project that I currently have, but there’s
no venture capital either, the
home is exactly it  also not a venture capital
case but it is more something that we,
so to speak, also butschek more a
bit because these boots shipping dna and
it often goes like this these discussions that
the vc world which as I said gets a lot of
attention
where I sometimes think some
Founders measure themselves by
whether they have a funding headline in German
startups or the founding scene, that's the
way it is  a vanity metric for you and
there is this boots trapping world
where people just fine
do their job every day
and finance themselves where
actually and on that finance
namely with sales from customers and the
war has much less attention
and yes  that's also our DNA and
that's why we're not vc
financed ourselves but are
actually several less boots
trapped ourselves but then with a little dead a
little bit of own funds too and the dead
also means criticism banks it has
if you want to buy something there
If the projects or
companies are profitable then a bank
comes along and just a device for that, well, it's really
easy, banks don't shy away from a
lot of digital topics, but it's
definitely easier than saying I
have a company here, which
maybe one day  sometime in ten years there will be an exit
so the world found case you
definitely get financed by the bank and that  it
's definitely a lot easier here with the saas topic
because
recurring is a bit like an
apartment building
where is your time the most
on it so for the topic so
the world found that
and
it's definitely a clear number
two
and yes then the
existing holdings ok ok and that's it
for you you want to do these things
openly for the long term
stop working you tell me
why we want to try new challenges
now somehow
also invest the money sensibly
then also a big effect yes absolutely
and i am also always involved in these projects for the
long term that i
have my last things so
i have  ten years at kusel if
now almost ten years with
me here i also like to handle
23 projects at the same time  el and do you
but then also ten years or 15
years or even longer that's I'm
like you again makes your
appearance belongs he starts throwing
claassen time goes now
a bit to operative topics
that interest me now
now understood or  what the
overall package of the school is right now, so
the various major construction sites then
probably big ones, it turns
out, but the various more
projects
at block, the market has
already changed a lot now there are always
new steven from google browser
extensions to prevent, so to speak, there is one
wave away from desktop relay to
mobile traffic so you could
see there too the company once made significantly
more results glockner well i
think we now have 430 somehow
or 28 times to check and then it went
down to still a lot but
almost ten times  less then it is also
because the market is somehow very
strong for a co  okie advertising market gladly
so the market is changing
the market is definitely changing a
lot now in addition to the its result
we are just like every german
gmbh a different register because the close
to the things you have to be a little
careful because in the  one
year there were simply one-off effects and as a
result the result was higher
than in the mainly after yes the
development is actually
constantly positive at
30 yes that was it was neither up
something where who who now celebrated internally because of
that nor down anything  where the
next year the minister said it
was a one-off effect
and it was therefore milder in both directions
than it actually looks but
otherwise you are right that the
environment is actually changing enormously
yes you mentioned the change in google
chrome  which are of course there right
now with vivo
google changing the basic structure of how
browser extensions also act  are allowed
and what they are allowed to do and that also
curtails
partly authorized copies
partly of course but
also to consolidate your own power and
that is of course constantly in flux and
yes but actually like everything you do on the
internet two years later
there are again many reasons
changes okay what does that mean
google is already
trying to work a little counter model
and say well well google
is of course already
trying to
control the value chain as much as possible and therefore of
course all things that google does are
always in the direction of how do i bring
more power to the  own platforms and
i don't think we are an exception and
generally the shift from desktops to
mobile lead to the topic
that's an issue for us because at logging was
actually more of a desktop
topic but in the meantime we have also concluded many contracts with
high-ranking ones
manufacturers of mobile browsers v  on
oems i.e. phone manufacturers
where we can then also bring more to mobile
because you ca
n’t usually install an extension on mobile
so it’s much
more difficult to install applockers
and that’s why you have to do it differently to
people but people want
to save something advertising is maybe  gotten a
bit better in the last
few years but there is still a
whole lot of annoying advertising and that's why
this own product what
people want is
there actually other entrepreneurs
that you might not
know that well now, but you know them too  let's
say successful film floor and
no longer looks clearly at people who
aren't so you can't still
there is something that and also at
login area there is relatively little
there is still yoga german this is
an independent project that stems from that
canadian but that's totally under the radar even
if you if the relatively tall si  And
there are a few smaller adblockers, but
there are also many that are in the
big browsers, so opera has
its own things,
edgar might still be there
, but there aren’t that many, so
we’ve already made sure that
we’re in  have a very good
position on the market so actively understood
that there are operational issues
like everywhere at world found i
would imagine is a topic that is
no longer so unique so i hear
on all sides that of course the cd
you have  also now others are also approaching us because we
are also committed and say that it is
also a business in the end to really make the world a
better place
here to say seriously that this
has caused politics and there is so much money
flowing down the rhine you also just
described there  are you no longer
with the wolf any more who are all
one now should do now there
are more and more coming recently even ashton
kutcher told me i would have now
also invested in a climate check of walls
and were lucky just now
is 1 1 on almost I absolutely so
there is a lot to do
but also a lot has to be created but if
you think about how much internet funds
or software or saas or blog chain
with all of them  there are ramifications then there
must be 100 times as many climate funds
in this world and hopefully we were
one of the early
ones but hopefully they won’t be the only ones but it’s also changing
incredibly like on the underside there
are more and more young
founding teams  they say i do
n't give myself into software and not in the block
chain and what but don't
really do what makes sense and i'm founding
an ecological and climate-friendly
startup and that's the quality and
the number of founding teams is also
factor 10 written in the  last
five years you just
said blog already at the beginning also
block is his topic i n  I wouldn't have been so
excited, but logically
you looked at the last one, what does
the rub-tinted climate also have to do with the fact that it
's so lasting at night and
after negative climate or what I had
with block chain are somehow more normal,
we say, aren't a logical step for
the generation  something to
do now and you would think you know
somehow enable
block chop waking up on the go yes it's a topic that
I haven't really found my way to listen to
so you thought
I would be 20 years younger
than the internet  came up when I was
in my teens, so to speak, or in
my early 20s, then my topic sounds
completely different than when you
are in your early 40s and that
may have played a role
found the perfect example where you
need the bells for a solution
where no other solution would work
the energy issue played at least
a  initially a role, but meanwhile
there are also frameworks with ministry
solana and all other variants
that are
significantly better than the
bitcoin variant the clock but I find that the
bitcoin itself I think is a
turnoff that means if you see it you
don’t either  yes, the different
schools of thought a lot of people here as
guests in the podcast they are extremely popular
is already building on it and investing in
it sometimes also really crass
projects and then there is the school of
thought that you are bringing up
and that I listen to more often now is like that
will be later and have understood then
you can also come quite well he came there
is simply no case recently was a
locksmith but a German entrepreneur
in the USA the oscar there somehow makes
it super deep is there I am too
so I would say but I would be
interesting  to see if there
are mainly people in the camp who are 40
plus or if you can find a few
20-year-olds or will e.g  20s
who are also in the camps is amazing
but if I'm now but you're 40plus
if mario that means where of which
I now know immediately from the last few weeks they
are open blog chain
skeptics
then I would say they are all
people maybe that's it  value is like
when you interview mail-order company manager at the end of the
90s that's funny on the
internet
that means if you now say ok checkout
type class projects so you have
indicated for block there is next
willingness to see if
there should be access looking for investors at
world found  namely a too well yes
definitely there you can join in so
it's not closed the woman and the
quadrupling under aspires
maybe also take it with you and then in case of
doubt a sensible
investment and you say that
and he has that's actually
[music]
Yes, I'm happy, too, when
things go forward because, above all, I
'm a poet, of course, but
also to  bias I think I've already
recognized so much that now it's just doing
well and the case
is yes is understandable and I find it
very also very convincing and
now I feel I've been with dahlias
just because now mine changed
to do something because because you
've been Japanese for a long time  because for me it's clear that it's
good so good, so I'm curious what's going
to be heard and I really hope
that in all three projects it will
happen that above all the last two
would
be close to our hearts and then maybe we won't see each other
again  four or five years but
because and 20 26 what used to be safe like
before here could be exactly
but you're doing it yourself so that he
also found it again as a dividend business in
the that's super successful the
world there you see your
classic model so in  the
management fee and kill is a
classic, exactly management 4 & carry
model of management, you
mainly run the team but clearly have the
back  I also have a
financial motivation to
do this on the targeted 4x because
then of course it's
usually worth 24 percent or 27 percent of
the profit and the management fees for us,
so there are now really big forests
and long attractive always around 1
percent  sometimes a lot of what
yes exactly two percent is the management
because then yes three stations will then be
7 million a year as a field there
you can do it if we manage the 950
million which we are now
assuming with that also you but also a
team of  20 25 people and they
really aren't
juniors either, they're also people in the business who have a lot of experience for are more expensive and + research plus data there's a lot have a lot of world imagine someday the law firm will be mega happy  it's the
diako cms hasche sigle from
cologne who's been doing an excellent
job for almost ten years
many millions many millions
g  ewon and then
[music]
maybe then
we'll hear each other exactly
this podcast is produced by
popstars
at mr